I ran into recently at an event for
someone we both know who passed away yes
sir and we saw each other at this event
and um we were chatting and I was
telling you every time I see you in
something I'm happy CU I am a big fan of
yours and your work and your persona and
Pokerface uh I just absolutely love I
love that show thank you and I know it
was bringing back a type of show that I
grew up watching as a kid this kind of
serialized person on the Move who
getting involved in things against her
will and and solving them and you're I
don't know I just I love that show
absolutely love that show and I was
really happy that you know you made it I
know that you've been deeply involved in
it you're not just acting in it but
you're you're wearing a lot of hats on
that show yeah yeah yeah uh yeah you
know I mean I just what's the humble
thing to say well much like Charlie
Chaplain uh I uh like Einstein you tried
something and it worked out you know
what I mean like so Ryan Johnson and I
are like this you know you see that one
photograph of uh Einstein and Charlie
Chaplan just looking Loose by the beach
on the Rock no one's ever seen that
photo you can Google that too yeah yeah
I've seen that photo you know that photo
that's a great photo so you know we're
in there yeah yeah I think I think if
they took a photo of you and me hanging
out at the beach it would be like
chaplain and Einstein it would it would
but different you know I mean cuz not
different at all baby we're
redheads so we got it like that what do
you either your thing or definitely
not how did oh there it is there they
are hanging out on a exactly we're
Googling everything you say yeah so and
so far so good right The Nut Job still
got it uh so I think Ryan I think I I
think Ryan is
Einstein yeah yeah yeah yeah because he
can do a Saturday crossw word although I
did have to help him uh at this uh AFI M
it's been you know show to show uh with
these ceremonies which is a nice thing
um but uh on Friday I had to help him
with the Friday puzzle while we sat and
watched the uh AFI Awards um and he was
very proud because his name was in the
puzzle you know uh director of knives
out out uh last name Johnson blank
Johnson I did that I did that one yeah
so he got that clue and many
others he so he got himself yeah and I
was like I'm proud of you but like you
Einstein usually you get the Saturday in
like eight minutes what's going on uh
Craig Mason was right across uh from us
so I made sure to shame Ryan to Craig
cuz that's very slow time for him and
then yeah and then I so that's why I
think he's Einstein uh because he can
generally under normal conditions do a
Saturday in like 8 minutes I can't I I
can't and I can't I can only do a up to
a Thursday and then again a Sunday
Friday and Saturday I don't even try you
are a so that's why I know I'm a Charlie
Chaplain I a regular I I do every single
times cross word puzzle yes and Monday I
find insulting like I'm just like what
is this you know not a dog but a c a you
know cat and and and so I'm Monday I'm I
just think I'm the smartest man in the
world yeah Tuesday sometimes there's a
struggle yeah for a moment or two and I
become and panicked that I'm an idiot
and then but then you get into it and I
have to say once you get into Friday
Saturday I don't know how anyone could
do Saturday in 8 minutes I don't think
that's possible uh I think Mason can and
I bet you uh Lord and Miller can um I'm
Jing about people you know that I've uh
puzzled with uh and I'm not name
dropping I'm puzzled dropping right now
so it's the nerdiest thing you can do is
puzzle droing yeah I'm puzzle
dropping like a yeah so I'm
out on I'm out on a yacht with h with
Will shorts yeah and uh you know the New
York Times cross puzzle editor it's
funny you bring up will because uh he
was so nice to me uh when I
co-constructed a puzzle for the times
with Deb amlin and it's it's not a big
deal Conan it's just like yeah I built
the puzzle and we shorts were
you know wrote me a nice note about it
and hey let me ask you how that works
kind of a big fan of mine so you know
what I mean like that's fine I
appreciate that you went to Harvard and
I dropped out NYU like six times at a
Tish wait why'd you drop out six times
once you drop out aren't you out n it's
just I kept trying to negotiate like a a
scholarship uh with the teen of
Admissions and cuz I was like I'm 15 you
know what I mean like what the you
want from me uh I don't have that's my
money you don't get my money
and you're going to college at 15 and
you're negotiating your own scholarship
or trying to or trying to and I think
yeah Bugsy Malone yeah did you have a
little cigarette or a little cigar yeah
of course I always have a little
cigarette thanks so much for bringing it
up because now I feel like it's an open
table for my real life's desires I still
do carry a lighter um on a lighter leash
but I I quit smoking
um but yeah I was trying to smoke in the
Dean's office uh so yeah but you're
Harvard and you ran the uh lampon and
right yeah sure but who cares no
one cares well I mean it's a long time
ago now so well not that long ago I'm
only 42 yeah and uh you've delivered on
it and I recently am 27 which is scary
because of the 27
Club you could go at any time
anytime